I noticed one other thing I noticed on
your board you have a magic square
that's correct why is that there today
and you know I spent part of my life
doing interviews and sometimes you have
to wear I think you know change bit from
the usual and so on that interview to
start with my Alice's to recall my
initial interesting mathematics when I
was a kid because the kind of thing that
I loved doing magic squares I think it's
one of the oldest mathematics memory
that I have doing large magic squares
there are techniques for doing the magic
squares when it's a even number but for
instance you would do like this child
can learn how to do this and I often
explain about this in the school it
gives you some sense of victory in the
power of mathematics and I'll go with
Nick there you are ready he passed logic
so if I saw that visit to enter time
journalist that's correct
but bit more than that
and in this particular case the
interview was intended for children if I
tell the children you know mathematics
is so good for the GDP because it's so
good for the technology and so on not
truly we like it but if I tell them when
I was a kid your age I'd love to do this
kind of figures and it was kind of
making me dizzy in a way to see the
properties of the numbers and
was my stuff and in the end he became my
child part how do you how do you sign
striking that balance sometimes when
you're talking to people about
mathematics you have to talk about
things like GDP and the important role
that plays in society and other times
you just want to show someone a magic
square and just excite them but is that
not enough exciting them do they ever
frustrate you that you're always having
to come up with you know these
justifications for mathematics you have
to justify part of the reason is that
there has been some excess in the past I
guess in insisting on mathematics for
itself mathematics for the beauty of it
and somehow we have to insist also on
the other side now but it's ok we have
to balance so every time I say something
about the utility of mathematics
I will balance it with something about
its beauty and vice versa
I sound usual to hear a mathematician
talk like that you have almost half
politician like you don't you see
you you think that so that's important
that pure mathematics is have enough
these days you've got you've got to know
you got to sing for your supper in front
of you is not just a mathematician and
director of Institute over the six years
for the past four years I have been you
know supporting a project of expanding
my institution and managed to raise sir
13 14 millions of euros for that project
this can only be achieved if you know
how to talk to society talking to
businessmen talking to bankers talking
to politicians talking to school masters
talking to everybody she don't manage to
talk the way they understand you will
not become their friend but when you
were young young the man and you know
doing some of your some of your work
your most famous for and most on water
for were you thinking like that men or
were you just doing it just for the
pleasure and I was it just about
mathematics then you know when I choose
my subject
both men equations it's like the root
for me the most men equation okay one
variant of the Bushmen equation
asked he's useful and who used it and
for me at that time this was an
important question to know that it was
important in the modeling of rarefied
gases important for you know
construction of shadows of planes of
miracle simulation of what goes on on
the wing of a plane or so on so
important for me and later when I worked
on it I discovered I really loved it for
the beauty of the study but the more I
was going into it and the more it was
well opening for me
so the curiosity that was riding me then
but to get into it I first had to be
convinced of its utility and I've no
shame in something being useful somehow
it's a little bit of poison that hobby
still in our minds making us healing
ashamed of what you useful you are other
days at a time and different contact now
we should not be ashamed of what you
useful and even understand that when it
is useful even more beautiful has to be
some useful and suddenly this sometimes
use who will become useless
sometimes you usually become useful
there has to be room for all kind of
mathematicians and it's a big illusion
to think that there is a real recipe to
decide what has to be funding and what
should not you know you have to allow
some uncertainty in the system
you try to predict you lose the most
interesting part do you think
mathematicians are good at outrage do
you think mathematicians were explaining
themselves in general mathematicians are
not so good at outreach and there are
reasons for that some regions are
related to the heal itself because we go
in such detail you know even between
ourselves mathematicians
to communicate so hard to communicate
between mathematicians of different
specialties talk to the outer public
outer audiences even greater challenge
have to really get to the point
understand what you want to share and so
on
another reason is when you are into
mathematics you have been so high on the
scale of complexity of reasoning that
you are living in some kind of distorted
reality you think that everybody on the
street is able to understand complicated
reasoning and so on and you get very
frustrated when you discover that not
the case and then there's a third reason
I guess which has to do with the way the
with the how to feed business model of
mathematics so to speak finish it you
know the chem is the biologists they are
often in contact with the industry all
the people who won big teams they have
to negotiate budgets funding with a big
pharmacy companies or with a bigger
sponsors otherwise we don't have enough
funding for the experiment and so on and
so they learn to develop Marisol and I
we talk that's Pete and so on it struck
me when I first attended the conferences
of Nobel Prizes how good was some of the
people Rob Nobel laureates in physics
and biology to present themselves and I
attributed that to the fact that they
had to do it already many times for the
funding in their career to people who
are really out of their world and it was
very important so to convince those
people to front them and what and
historically mathematicians donate as
much funding historically we don't need
the the companies historically no no
such need for support I need the
companies now because I am working on
this outreach intersected we are soon
opening some kind of Museum of
mathematics soon meaning three years or
something and this will be impossible
without the contribution of the
indiscreet economic one so I have to
learn to talk to them otherwise my
project could not have come to life on
this phenomena which are D which are
dear to pieces please look at the
lattice on the other side because it's
also important